let's go to Dave from Northern
California Dave from Northern California
welcome to the program uh would love to
hear what is on your mind today
Dave from Northern California please
accept my invitation to join the
discussion
hi David hi
how are you today okay
um I was calling to talk about your plan
to try to reduce gun violence sure I
agree with you in principal I share the
same goals
but I come from the perspective of
knowing that there are
easily over a hundred million
semi-automatic Firearms most people have
at least two magazines I've met people
who have a hundred magazines that are
over the capacity limit that you've
talked about in the past I don't see how
any law that could be passed
would successfully rid the world over
the country of those firearms and I've
got anecdotal cases
um for why I think any law would still
be defeatable with current technology
well so how do your absolutely suppose
that would work it's it's not really I
mean I've already addressed that in the
formulation of my proposal which is
there is no one law that will solve the
problem but what we want to do given
that there's a second amendment and
given that there are hundreds of
millions of guns out there we want to
see can we reduce can we reduce and so
you're absolutely right I mean listen
part parts of the proposals are you
require licensing maybe some of the
people I'm sorry you require Insurance
some of the people who have a whole
bunch of firearms might say hey you know
what I don't want to pay as much in
insurance so I will choose to get rid of
some of these weapons you have a gun
buyback program for certain firearms
that doesn't mean anyone's forced to
give them back but you give an off-ramp
to people so I agree I mean I don't know
that we disagree I'm on the same page as
you there given the circumstances and
where we are today there is no one law
that's going to solve the problem but
what I want to do is say is there
low-hanging fruit that does doesn't
violate the second amendment that we can
use to help and improve the problem
that's where I am
well so the reason that I find that
argument unconvincing uh is Illustrated
with an example from close to me uh last
week a gentleman was arrested
um in possession of methamphetamine for
sale he was a convicted felon and he had
a gun on him that prompted uh a search
of his home where they located two more
Firearms one of which was a AR-15 that
was one of these um ghost guns although
that phrase is really mocked within the
gun Community I think it's better to say
a built at home gun from a kit
um and this person was a convicted felon
in a state like California that has
restrictions against AR-15s this wasn't
compliant in any of the ways that the
laws in California and he made the gun
himself at home I've seen documentaries
that claim over 150 million blanks have
been sold for making these Firearms so
I'm just extremely pessimist that that
strategy can work
yeah and like I said you're you're sort
of proving my point which is of course
you're going to have stories like that
and you are right it's possible that my
10 ideas wouldn't have prevented this
guy in California from having built a
gun and I don't I don't purport to have
a solution to that so again I don't
think we're in disagreement I think
we're up against a real challenge here
but we can't say since it won't solve
that problem you just identified we
should do nothing that I can't get
behind
yeah
yeah and I understand that
um very much I guess what I'm trying to
do is is direct the conversation towards
Solutions I think have any chance
whatsoever and the political give me one
such solution I've got 40 people waiting
but give me one such solution we can
think about and then I'm gonna move on
okay
well um that that's the problem is I
don't have one and I understand
completely what you're saying it's time
to move on um so thank you very much for
taking my call and um congratulations on
the birth of your child all right Dave
from Northern California great to hear
from you